de l'action des cartes du foot trois
jeux trois tournois trois styles pour la
troisième édition un mât team a choisi
d'ouvrir de nouveaux tournois pour viser
un public plus large que le fait qu'ils
aient plus de choix basse permet aux de
rassembler et puis au niveau de bakun de
versailles d'acheter un petit peu la
même idée c'est qu'il avait eu des
retours comme quoi il y avait des gens
qui trouvent une initiative très bonne
mais comme c'était pas sur le jeu au
pied qui jouait bas il se trouait sans
voix il digéré l'impression d'un peu
moins participent à la fête le jeu qu'on
a fait les deux premières années
toujours la personne parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a réussi à créer un rendez
vous donc l'idée ce n'est pas de tout
perdre
mais voilà avec les nouveaux jeux
d'ouvrir de nouvelles personnes pour
ceux qui voudraient affronter les
champions les joueurs professionnels
invités le rendez vous est donné dès
midi pour s'inscrire des tournois à
l'inscription gratuite
là on a choisit plutôt de faire des
compétitions qu'ils font et beaucoup de
personnes présentes
donc on a quand même plus de 100 joueurs
sur tf t on à 64 joueurs sur fifa 32 sur
leur stone aubrac les les tournois sont
vraiment faits pour pouvoir encaisser on
va dire un grand nombre de participants
près de sept cents passionnés et curieux
s'étaient donné rendez vous l'an dernier
armes à steam vous attend ce samedi 8
février à l'hôtel de ville de versailles
il vous reste encore quelques heures
pour vous entraîner